[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il était une fois un petit garçon qui
s'appelait bachir il avait un papa qui
s'appelait saïd est une poupée qui
s'appelait scooby doo
saïd était un bon papa et scooby 12
n'était pas une poupée comme les autres
elle avait le pouvoir magique de voir le
passé et l'avenir
il suffisait pour cela de lui bander les
yeux
un beau matin il va pas ça des lots j'ai
pas d'argent
et puis l'année prochaine tu auras
grande île et il sera trop petit vélo
bachir n'insista pas mais le soir il
demanda à scooby doo dix mois tant pis
c'est tout quand elle jure un vélo je
vois un vélo mais pas avant un an ou
deux au juge van ne te désole pas je
vais partir et dans ce nom je reviendrai
avec tomber l'eau cependant j'ai besoin
de quelque chose comme tu ne seras pas
là pour me bander les yeux
il me faut une paire de lunettes noires
d'accord et scooby doo s'en fout
[Musique]
elle arriva dans un grand port communeau
[Rires]
excuse fr je sais dire le passé bien
venir et les choses cachées
vous avez une famille avec un enfant
blond vous avez une femme à singapour
avec deux enfants jaune
vous avez une femme à dakar avec six ans
c'est assez il voit plutôt le temps
qu'il fera demain il fera très mauvais
temps et vous ne pourrez pas sortir du
port et bien parions si demain il fait
mauvais temps
je termine avec moi une idée de roubaix
je te laisse ici est en effet le
lendemain la tempête ce lot
[Musique]
l'ue a gagné poupée je t'amène à payer
pour acheter l'un des nôtres bachir
c'est convenu et c'est ainsi que scooby
doo fit le tour du monde en annonçant le
camp sans jamais se tromper
jusqu'au jour et quelques instants plus
tard dis-moi poupée quel temps fera t-il
demain je ne peux pas vous dire monsieur
marin je ne voulais même n'a eu lui de
toupah lunettes tu dois me dire le temps
qu'ils fois 3e v2 payés à rien faire
hélas le lendemain dès l'aube un gros
nuage surgi à l'horizon le marin dorin
furieux et
[Musique]
et
qu'est ce que je vais devenir ici mon
pauvre match qui attend son bus la mêlée
ne sert qu'à valletoux bonjour poupée
bonjour litres
que cette perle me gêne si je pouvais
trouver quelqu'un qui me débarrasse de
cette saleté je te l'enlève si tu veux à
l'abandon je peux acheter cinq ou six
vélos à bachir ouvre toi toute grande et
là c'est fini
merci huîtres commente il faire pour
rentrer chez moi tu n'as qu'à te
balancer d'un pied sur l'autre leur cas
sera malade il fera ce que tu voudras en
effet au bout de deux minutes il eu le
ok hollow c'est fini le dos je ne reçois
pas tort de ma nourriture avait c'est ou
paris commentant la scène
terminus tout le monde descend
les fils et que je te revois plus nager
dans de l'eau douche je suis déshonoré
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
papa saïd je suis très content la perle
fut vendu un bijoutier et bachir eu un
très joli vélo
[Musique]